.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
(Sprechchor) AJZ.
* Knall *
Die Stärke der Bewegung machte aus,
dass Leute fanden:
"Darauf reagieren wir."
(Frau) Freedom and sunshine
for Giorgio Bellini.
(Polizeidurchsage) Das ist
eine unbewilligte Demonstration.
Was man
als Jugendbewegung bezeichnet,
ist keine Jugendbewegung.
* Punk-Song: "Razzia" von TNT *
# Razzia, Razzia,
eusi Schmier isch wider da.
Wir lassen nicht zu,
dass der Kanton Zürich
zum europäischen Sammelbecken
von Krawallanten und Chaoten wird.
Die Polizei macht das schon richtig,
und ich bin ein Rädchen,
das mithilft.
Das habe ich
nicht gross hinterfragt.
# Und es git e Razzia.
Das war eine wunderbare Mischung
aller möglichen Ausdrucksformen.
# Razzia, Razzia,
kei Kontrolle über eus ha.
* Knall *
* Fröhliche Musik *
Willy Schaffner.
Heute Hobbyfischer,
damals Polizeispitzel.
Er begegnet in diesem Film einem der
berühmtesten Aktivisten der Bewegung.
Dessen Auftritt im Fernsehen
als Herr Müller
sorgte 1980
für einen landesweiten Skandal.
Ich war nirgends wirklich sicher.
Es passierte einige Male,
dass an überraschenden Orten
Leute auftauchten.
Als ich einmal auf der Göscheneralp
Richtung Damma-Einlauf
unterwegs war,
kamen mir drei Personen entgegen.
Weil ich ständig
mit dem Feldstecher umherschaute,
erkannte ich die drei Leute.
Es waren drei Personen,
die sich in der Szene bewegten,
denen ich
nicht unbedingt begegnen wollte.
Ich hatte
eine relativ einfache Tarnung:
Ich tarnte mich
durch eine Art Bauernschläue.
Dazumal hat das standgehalten,
heute würde das
nicht mehr standhalten.
* Knipsen *
* Neue-Deutsche-Welle-Song:
"Eisbär" von Grauzone *
# Eisbär, kaltes Eis, kaltes Eis.
Als Barbara Ellmerer zu Beginn
der 80er-Jahre nach Zürich kam,
war die Jugendbewegung
schon in vollem Gang.
Elektrisiert von der kreativen
Energie tauchte die Bernerin ein
und engagierte sich
in der Kultur- und der Frauengruppe.
Heute ist sie bildende Künstlerin
mit Ausstellungen
in der Schweiz und im Ausland.
Ihre feministische Haltung
lebt sie in Beruf und Alltag.
Es war der totale Aufbruch.
Im Nachhinein sehe ich die Bewegung
wirklich als mind opener.
Und das war sie auf allen Ebenen.
Man konnte sich neu definieren:
Wie will ich mein Leben gestalten?
Politisch und genderpolitisch
sowieso, aber auch künstlerisch.
Das war ein Feld
ungeahnter Möglichkeiten.
* Knipsen *
Gar niemand weiss mehr,
in welchem Zustand
sich die Stadt damals befand:
Zürich war eine extrem verschlafene
Stadt, extrem verschlossen
und etwas hinter dem Mond,
wie man heute sagen würde.
Ich habe den ganzen Tag nichts an-
deres zu tun, als arbeiten zu gehen.
Und was darf ich in meiner
wenigen Freizeit tun? Konsumieren.
Es geht darum,
dass wir einen Ort haben,
wo wir unser Ding machen können
und in Ruhe gelassen werden.
Wo will man heute noch hin?
An ein Good-News-Konzert für 24 Fr.
Das ist lächerlich.
Wir mussten arbeiten,
darum sollen die anderen auch,
dann vergehen ihnen die Flausen.
Wenn sie nicht wissen, was sie
mit ihrer Freizeit anfangen sollen,
sollen sie weiterarbeiten
oder ein gutes Buch lesen.
Das wäre auch eine Idee -
statt herumzuschreien.
Es gab eine Sperrstunde
um Mitternacht. Diese Stadt war tot.
Das war eigentlich tiefste Provinz.
* Fröhliche elektronische Musik *
Fredy Meier alias Herr Müller gehörte
1980 zu den treibenden Kräften.
Seiner Originalität und Kreativität
verdankte die Bewegung
eigenwillige Aktionen.
In den Geschichtsbüchern steht:
"Aufbruch."
Das ist ein sehr gutes Wort,
Aufbruch.
Damals herrschte eine Stimmung von:
"Komm, lass es uns versuchen."
"He, das können wir doch."
"Was?"
"Ich weiss auch nicht recht,
aber lass es uns versuchen."
Diese Spannung,
bevor man etwas beginnt,
aber noch gar nicht recht weiss,
wie man es machen will.
* Knipsen *
Erstmals seit einer 1980 gemeinsam
im Gefängnis verbrachten Nacht
begegnen sich
Aktivist und Spitzel wieder.
Fredy.
- Hoi, Willy, freut mich.
Schön, dich zu sehen.
Sie kehren an jenen Ort zurück,
wo alles begonnen hat.
Schon seit Jahren forderte
Zürichs Jugend einen Freiraum.
Als der Stadtrat
1980 für das Opernhaus
einen Millionenkredit sprach,
brachte dies das Fass zum Überlaufen.
Von einem autonomen Jugendzentrum
wollten die Verantwortlichen
nach wie vor nichts wissen.
Das mobilisierte viele Jugendliche.
Ich habe noch eine Information
im Zusammenhang
mit der Opernhaus-Abstimmung,
bei der
ein 60-Mio.-Kredit vorgelegt wird,
mit dem die Bürger
wiederum ihr Scheissopernhaus
noch etwas schöner
zurechtflicken sollen,
um ihre Scheisskultur
dort konsumieren zu können.
Aus diesem Grund
veranstalten wir eine Aktion.
Und diese Aktion findet statt
am 30. dieses Monats,
also am 30. Mai.
Vor dem Opernhaus waren Polizisten
zum Schutz der Zuschauer
in Stellung gegangen.
Die Stimmung war aufgeheizt.
Das ist beim Eingang zum Opernhaus,
wo die Polizisten
mit Helmen bereitstehen.
Interessanterweise trugen sie damals
noch diese geflochtenen Schilde,
die, so viel ich weiss, in einem
Behindertenheim hergestellt wurden.
* Unverständliche Polizeidurchsage,
gefolgt von Pfiffen. *
Für die Polizisten, die dort
standen, war das nicht angenehm.
Wenn man diese Bilder so betrachtet,
merkt man ganz genau,
was die Leute mit ihrer Anwesenheit
ausdrücken wollen:
"Okay, jetzt gehen wir mal hin
und schauen einmal."
Aber diese Bilder lassen nicht
wirklich eine Absicht erkennen.
"Die Demonstranten
nahmen Baumaterial,
das sie sich zuvor
bereitgelegt hatten."
Diese Auslegung der Tatsachen
war völliger Quatsch.
Es hat sich so ergeben,
niemand wollte von Anfang an aktiv
die Polizei mit Latten bewerfen.
Richtig.
Und bevor man wusste, was los war,
ging es plötzlich ab.
Ja, und dann ist
eben dieser Schuss gefallen.
Erst rannten bloss
einzelne Polizisten auf uns zu.
Und dann wurde natürlich ...
Jetzt müssen wir nicht
zu philosphieren beginnen,
welche Reaktion ein Polizist
in Vollmontur hervorruft,
wenn er auf 20 Leute losrennt.
Dann rennt man nicht davon,
sondern findet:
"He, Bulle, hau ab!"
Wir arbeiteten auch
bis tief in die Nacht,
wenn du vom Wochenenddienst
der Polizisten erzählst.
Auch wir
haben nächtelang gearbeitet,
und dabei viel weniger verdient,
hatten auch keinen Beamtenstatus.
Jetzt, fast 40 Jahre später,
kann ich das so sagen:
Für uns war es
tatsächlich nicht so lustig.
Wir standen
von der Politik unter Druck,
die keinen Plan hatte.
Auch unsere Führung wusste nicht,
was zu tun war.
Man war mit seinem Latein am Ende.
Schau dir das an!
Weisst du, es gibt auch
eine Ästhetik des Widerstands.
Und wenn dann aber nur noch
von Gewalt geschrieben wird,
von Gewalt gegen Sachen,
geht gerne vergessen,
dass z.B. Tisch und Stühle
auf einer Strasse,
die sonst von Autos befahren wird,
etwas Schönes,
einen Reiz an sich hat.
Damit wollte man
niemanden schlagen, sondern ...
Ja, ja.
Und Schaufenster, na ja ...
Das klingt jetzt
doch etwas verharmlosend.
Nein, wirklich nicht,
das würde ich nie.
Das nehme ich so zur Kenntnis.
* Scheppern *
Die Bilanz dieser Nacht:
hoher Sachschaden, 45 Verhaftungen
und verhärtete Fronten.
Der Stadtrat ignorierte die Forderung
der Jugendlichen weiterhin.
Solange Krawall
auf den Strassen stattfindet,
verhandeln wir nicht mit
Jugendlichen, das können wir nicht.
Wir müssen
die Rechtsordnung respektieren.
* Buhrufe *
Doch die Jugendlichen
liessen nicht locker.
Sie forderten vom Stadtrat nun ulti-
mativ ein autonomes Jugendzentrum.
Sie wollten eine konkrete Zusage
und setzten der Stadt eine Frist.
Der Stadtrat
stellt der Zürcher Jugend
die leer stehende Fabrikhalle
an der Limmatstrasse
hinter dem Carparkplatz,
welche sich im Besitz der Stadt
befindet,
ab kommendem Sonntag 12 Uhr
zur Verfügung.
* Jubel *
Ich habe vorhin gesagt,
dass wir es für möglich halten,
etwas in diesem Gebäude
an der Limmatstrasse einzurichten,
das euren Wünschen entspricht.
Trotz der Aussicht
auf ein Jugendzentrum
trauten die Jugendlichen
dem Stadtrat nicht.
Es war von Anfang an klar,
dass keine kompetenten Leute
hierherkommen würden,
und in keiner Art und Weise auf un-
sere Forderungen eingegangen würde.
Was müsste denn noch mehr kommen?
Ganz konkret:
ein Jugendhaus in Selbstverwaltung.
Daran führt jetzt
wohl kein Weg mehr vorbei.
* aggressive Punkmusik *
Es folgten weitere Demonstrationen.
Der Druck auf den Stadtrat wuchs.
Hilfe!
Geht es wieder los?
Wieso haben Sie uns
mit Polizeigewalt ...
Das war also schon sehr brutal.
Als kleine, feine Frau
wurde man
von der Polizei gleich behandelt
wie ein 1,80 m grosser Kollege.
Man musste extrem präsent
und stark sein,
wenn man sich dem aussetzte.
Wie weiter?
Politik und Polizei setzten
nach der ersten Demonstrationswelle
auf den Geheimdienst.
Der Plan:
Beamte der Sondereinheit KK III
sollten die Jugendbewegung
infiltrieren.
In diesem Gebäude
an der Stampfenbachstrasse 63
trugen die verdeckt
operierenden Polizisten
Insiderinformationen zusammen.
Willy Schaffner, der 29-jährige
Polizist aus dem Urnerland,
witterte seine Chance.
Er bewarb sich.
Damals gab es noch keine eigentliche
Ausbildung zum Polizeispitzel.
Man wusste wohl etwas,
etwas weniges.
Es gab in dieser Abteilung
vereinzelt Mitarbeiter,
die etwas darüber wussten, aber es
gab keine eigentliche Ausbildung.
Ich muss vielleicht erwähnen,
dass Polizeikreise vermuteten,
dass die Unruhen
bald abebben würden.
Sie würden eine Woche,
zwei, drei Wochen dauern,
aber schliesslich
dauerten sie fast zwei Jahre.
Dadurch entstand
ein Informationsmangel.
Deshalb wurden die Jüngsten
in der Abteilung beauftragt:
"Geht doch einmal schauen",
lautete der Spruch:
"Wir haben keine Informationen."
"Wer sind die Drahtzieher?
Wann ist was geplant?"
Weil Politik und Führung
total überfordert war,
wurde dieses Instrument geschaffen.
Im KK III verwandelte sich
der einfache Polizist Willy Schaffner
in den Spitzel Schaller Willi -
inklusive Ausweis
und Undercoverwohnung an der
Badenerstrasse mitten in Zürich.
Schaller Willi, Badenerstrasse 85 -
stimmt, sehr einfallsreich.
Habt ihr diesen Ausweis
selbst hergestellt?
Ja, sicher
habe ich ihn selbst gemacht.
Keine schlechte Arbeit.
Es hat relativ einfach funktioniert.
- Unglaublich.
Zur Tarnung
passte sich Willy der Szene an.
Er liess sich die Haare
und einen Bart wachsen.
Die Spitzeltätigkeit
war längst mehr als nur ein Job.
Sein gesamtes Leben veränderte sich
und führte ihn an die rote Linie -
und darüber hinaus.
Mit der Ausweisbeschaffung
wurde die rote Linie überschritten.
Identitätskarten
auf falsche Namen lautend,
das war sicher
nicht gerade regelkonform.
Es ist ein seltsames Gefühl,
wenn man nicht derjenige ist,
der man eigentlich sein sollte.
Das ist seltsam.
Es ist auch nicht nachahmenswert.
Heute habe ich ein sehr ...
Selbst nach so vielen Jahren
bleibt ein sehr seltsames Gefühl.
Es ist nicht ...
Man sollte das eigentlich nicht tun.
Das Doppelleben hat seinen Preis.
Auch privat war es für meine
damalige Freundin und heutige Frau
alles andere
als angenehm oder lustig.
Hier.
- Danke. Tschüss.
Fütterst du noch die Hühner?
- Ja.
Sie warnte mich immer und sagte:
"Das könnte sich rächen."
Aber ich blieb
stur und uneinsichtig.
Aber so wie es nachher ausging,
hatte sie letztlich doch recht.
Hier ist die legendäre Nummer 63.
Es hatte auch schöne Seiten,
aber letztlich ...
Und hier war der Eingang.
- Ja, das war der Eingang.
Während der Jugendunruhen
nahmen wir in einer ersten Phase
immer nur den Hintereingang.
Wenn aber eine VV
oder Demonstration war,
mussten wir
einen weiten Umweg machen
und achtgeben, dass uns niemand
folgt. Das wäre fatal gewesen.
Mehr als 60 Personen
arbeiteten während der Jugendunruhen
im Kriminalkommissariat III,
etwa zwölf
waren als Spitzel im Einsatz.
Der Auftrag lautete:
Aufrechterhaltung
der inneren Sicherheit.
Die Aktivität der Politischen Polizei
steuerte während der Jugendbewegung
auf ihren Höhepunkt zu.
Tausende Fichen wurden angelegt.
Bis zum Fichenskandal im Jahr 1989
belief sich die Zahl der Fichen
allein in der Stadt Zürich
auf 55'000.
Das sind Fotos, die wir
in den 80er-Jahren geschossen haben.
Dank dieser Aufnahmen
konnten wir Leute identifizieren,
in deren Fichen wir das mit einem
entsprechenden Eintrag vermerkten.
Okay.
Die Stadt lenkte ein.
Am 28. Juni 1980 war es so weit.
In einem leer stehenden Gebäude
neben dem Hauptbahnhof Zürich
konnten sich die Jugendlichen
ihren eigenen Raum einrichten.
Bei der Eröffnung des
autonomen Jugendzentrums, kurz AJZ,
wurde noch gehämmert und geschraubt.
Emilie Lieberherr,
die Vorsteherin des Sozialamts,
machte sich vor Ort ein Bild.
Wie sehen Sie die Zukunft
für das Zürcher Jugendhaus?
Für dieses hier?
- Ja.
Es kommt ganz darauf an,
was damit gemacht wird.
Ich glaube an eine gewisse Form
der Selbstverwaltung.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
* Wilde Punkmusik *
Das AJZ
war eigentlich ein Bienenhaus,
in dem sich alle getroffen haben,
die mit den bürgerlichen Strukturen
nicht zufrieden waren.
Da waren
die sprühenden Intellektuellen,
und die noch sprühenderen
Gestalterinnen und Künstler.
Aber was natürlich schwierig war,
war der Umgang mit der Sogwirkung,
die das AJZ
auf Outstands und natürlich
auch Drogenabhängige hatte.
Es kam der Stadt
damals nicht ungelegen,
dass sie sich auf diese Art
derer entledigen konnte,
während wir uns mit
diesen Problemen konfrontiert sahen.
Es gab z.B. einen Fixerraum,
wo wir die Drogenabhängigen
auch noch betreut haben.
Das AJZ hätte sehr leicht von
innen heraus kaputtgehen können.
Es bestand ein ewiger Kampf,
das Gleichgewicht halten zu können
zwischen konstruktiven
und destruktiven Kräften.
* Punkmusik *
Das AJZ hatte auch ungebetene Gäste.
Spitzel der Stadtpolizei
mischten sich unter die Besucher,
einer davon war Willy Schaffner.
Was im AJZ ablief, passt mir nicht.
Meist blieb ich im Vorhof.
Ich ging schon gelegentlich rein,
hielt mich aber
nicht extensiv im Innern auf
und engagierte mich auch nicht -
es lief mir zuwider.
Das lag an den Drogen,
aber auch an den nicht optimalen
hygienischen Verhältnissen.
Ich hatte ein zwiespältiges
Verhältnis zum Ganzen dort.
Wo sich früher das AJZ befand,
halten heute Fernbusse und Reisecars.
Willy und Fredy machen sich ein Bild,
wo 1980 was stand.
Das Gebäude stand auf dieser Seite,
in dieser Richtung.
Ja, genau.
Auf dieser Höhe lag der Eingang.
- Jawohl.
Im vorderen Bereich war die Kneipe.
- Genau, ja.
Und etwa hier,
also im unteren Bereich,
stand die grosse Halle.
- Genau.
Wobei gross ...
Es war keine angenehme Halle.
- Nein, nicht wirklich.
Nach einer Vollversammlung mussten
wir die Informationen übermitteln,
was beschlossen wurde. In der Regel
gab es immer eine Anschlussaktion.
Es gab verschiedene Varianten,
um das zu kommunizieren,
u.a. mit dem sog. Mützen-Trick.
D.h., wenn ich mit einer schwarzen
Mütze das Lokal verliess,
beobachtete mich
einer unserer Kollegen,
sei das einer in einem Horst
oder einer zu Fuss,
der das der Einsatzleitung meldete:
"Willi ist gekommen.
Heute passiert nichts mehr."
Wenn ich das Lokal aber
mit einer rote Mütze verliess,
hiess das ...
So ein Quatsch!
Nein, so war das! Dann hiess das:
"Es passiert noch etwas.
Haltet die Leute bereit."
"Es formiert sich noch
ein Demonstrationszug."
Grossartig!
Die wirklich wilden Aktionen
besprachen wir nie im AJZ.
Wir informierten uns damals schon
über mögliche Verwanzung der Räume
und Überwachung.
Gab es Momente, in denen du
der Polizei auf der Gegenseite
sogar etwas Verständnis
entgegenbringen konntest?
Ich will es so formulieren:
Ich bin kein nachtragender Mensch,
aber ich bin auch
kein vergesslicher Mensch.
* Treibende elektronische Klänge *
Die Bewegung überraschte
mit immer neuen, kreativen Aktionen.
Ein Auftritt
von Vertretern der Bewegung
sorgte im Juli 1980
für einen der grössten Skandale
in der Geschichte
des Schweizer Fernsehens.
Zur Diskussion dieser Fragen
im Studio
haben wir einige Leute eingeladen.
Links von mir sitzen zwei Vertreter
der Zürcher Jugendbewegung:
Anna Müller und Hans Müller
Zu diesem Auftritt kam es,
weil jemand vom Schweizer Fernsehen
ins AJZ gekommen war
und gefragt hatte:
"Hättet ihr nicht Lust?
Würdet ihr kommen?"
Erst fanden wir natürlich
kategorisch: "Nein."
Niemand wollte
im Fernsehen auftreten.
Aber als wir merkten, dass es sich
um eine Livesendung handelte,
dass Frau Lieberherr und
Stadtrat Frick anwesend sein würden,
wie auch Polizeikommandant Bertschi,
sahen wir es
als Möglichkeit für einen Auftritt,
bei dem wir das Gegenteil darstellen
wollten, was von uns erwartet wurde.
Wir spielten
rechtsgerichtete Bürgerliche,
die z.T. sogar noch
faschistische Sprüche äusserten.
Das war unser Plan.
Die Mehrheit fand:
"Okay, Hayat und Fredy."
Und so gingen wir
durch diese Sendung.
Wenn man schaut, was die Jungen
an diesem Wochenende versucht haben,
sind das alles lächerliche Vorwürfe.
Was wir heute brauchen,
ist die Armee.
Ich plädiere:
Ohne Armee werden wir dieser
Jugendbewegung nicht mehr Herr.
Und dann steht morgen
die Revolution vor der Tür,
und dann habt ihr den Dreck.
Ich habe es jetzt gesagt.
Wenn man das nächste Mal
gegen jemanden wie diese Kinder
wirklich vorgehen will,
sollte man wirklich
mit Salzsäure oder so was vorgehen.
Der Vorwurf liegt,
so schätze ich, auf Ihrer Seite.
Darf ich ...
Dazu will ich etwas sagen.
Wir sehen heute Abend wieder,
wie die beiden,
diese Dame und dieser Herr,
diese Sendung nur benutzen,
um sich lächerlich zu machen,
und nicht, um zu diskutieren.
Gegen diesen Vorwurf will ich mich
entschieden zur Wehr setzen.
Das akzeptiere ich nicht.
(Moderator) Jeder hat das Recht,
hier zu reden.
Und nachher gab es einen Polizei-
einsatz mit, schauen Sie genau,
mit solchen Gummipatrönchen.
Das Einzige,
was ich dazu sagen kann:
Sie wurden seit dem letzten Krawall
8 g schwerer.
Aber mit solchen Gummipatrönchen
kann man doch nicht so militante
Leute vertreiben wollen.
Diejenigen,
die in Irland verwendet werden,
sind etwa so lang und so dick.
Darüber kann man reden, ob das
ein sinnvolles Einsatzmittel ist.
Das ist eine CB-Granate,
von der dauernd behauptet wird,
sie sei krebsfördernd.
Hoffentlich ist sie es,
hoffentlich ist sie krebsfördernd.
Herr Hiermeyer, wenn Sie
nicht Herr der Lage ...- Kriesemer.
Herr Kriesemer, wenn Sie nicht Herr
der Lage werden, laufe ich davon.
Ich finde es unerhört,
was die beiden bieten:
Sie beherrschen das ganze Gespräch.
Wir können keine
unbewilligten Demonstrationen ...
Reisst endlich die alten Häuser ab,
damit die sich nicht in Kommunen
und Wohngemeinschaften
zusammenrotten können.
Und teert endlich
die Kinderspielplätze,
wir brauchen
mehr Parkplätze.
(Moderator) Was passiert, wenn es
nochmals eine Demonstration gibt?
Ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Anwesenheit.
An die Wand stellen!
- An die Wand stellen!
Und KZs könnte Sie auch noch bauen.
Der Dialog ist heutzutage
etwas schwierig.
Danke vielmals und auf Wiedersehen.
Moskau - kann ich nur sagen. Moskau.
Nach unserem Auftritt
gingen wir ins AJZ zurück,
wo das alle
wunderbar und toll fanden.
Dort gab es
ein Fest wegen dieser Sendung.
Diese Sendung
hat schweizweit Aufsehen erregt.
Damit wurde das Schweizer Fernsehen
in dieselbe Ecke gestellt:
Das ist auch
eine linke Gesellschaft usw.
Intern war der Tenor:
Das Fernsehen steckt
unter derselben Decke.
(Polizeidurchsage) Ohne weitere
Warnung wird Tränengas eingesetzt.
Haut ab!
Innerhalb von zwei Tagen nach
dieser Sendung wurden unsere Namen,
also nicht Herr Hans
und Frau Anna Müller,
sondern unsere bürgerlichen Namen
wurden in der Presse genannt.
Und das führte dazu,
dass Hayat ganz klar massiv stärker
angegangen wurde als ich:
Sie erhielt Morddrohungen.
Eine Frau, die frech ist,
das ging damals einfach nicht.
* Schwungvolle Punkmusik *
Wir waren keine Opfer,
wir waren Aktivistinnen.
Wir standen als Frauen da - fertig!
Das mussten sie eben lernen,
dass wir da waren.
* Sie lacht. *
Im AJZ sind sofort
ein paar Frauen zusammengekommen,
die sich zur Frauengruppe
zusammengeschlossen haben.
Wir waren nicht nur
ständig an Demos auf der Strasse,
sondern haben schon früh wirklich
begonnen, seriös zu arbeiten.
Das Sexualstrafrecht
war in Revision.
Und dazu gab es einen Vorentwurf.
Dieser Vorentwurf
beinhaltete z.B.,
dass Vergewaltigungen
straffrei werden,
wenn sich Opfer und Täter kennen.
Da mussten wir
natürlich dagegenhalten.
* Punkmusik mit weiblichem Gesang *
Wir waren also illegal unterwegs,
wenn man so will.
Es hat uns
auch eine tolle Energie gegeben.
Aber es ging nicht nur
um die Illegalität per se,
sondern es war alles
Mittel zum Zweck.
Die Leute begannen auch,
nachzudenken.
Viele Sachen, die heute normal sind,
waren es damals noch nicht.
* aggressive Punkmusik
mit weiblichem Gesang *
Hast du auch Steine geworfen?
Hat es das auch gebraucht?
Ja, sicher.
Ja, sicher. "Unter dem Pflaster
liegt der Strand."
Nach einer Demo
sind meine Freundin und ich
nackt auf die Bühne geklettert
und haben nichts anderes gesagt als:
"In einer Viertelstunde
beginnt dort vorne die Nacktdemo."
"Gebt eure Kleider bitte
einem Kumpel oder einer Kollegin."
"Kommt ohne Kleider,
dann gehen wir los."
In jener Zeit
trug ich einen Gipsverband,
weil ich in der ersten Nacht
der Demos verletzt wurde.
Damals gab es noch Frauen,
die nackt getanzt haben:
die Striptease-Tänzerinnen.
Und diese Frauen
kamen tatsächlich aus den Lokalen
und klatschten
und hatten eine Riesenfreude.
Aber sie brauchten einen Moment,
um zu verstehen, was genau abläuft.
Sie waren sonst immer nackt,
und jetzt waren wir es.
Als einige Demoteilnehmer
gefragt wurden:
"Warum habt ihr
diese Nacktdemo gemacht?"
antworteten sie natürlich:
"Das war, um zu zeigen:
nackt gegen Gewalt."
Also ein pädagogischer Moment.
Aber für uns hatte es
überhaupt nicht damit zu tun.
Wir hatten einfach Lust, das zu tun.
Basta, bumm, fertig.
Nach der Pensionierung
zog Willy Schaffner
zurück in seine Urner Heimat.
Seit 2016 wohnt er mit
seiner Frau Margrith in Gurtnellen.
Hier nahm er
ein Buchprojekt in Angriff
über seine Zeit als Polizeispitzel.
* Fröhliche Handorgelmusik *
Hast du dir damit
etwas von der Seele geschrieben?
War das eine Last?
Viele Kollegen ziehen es vor,
zu schweigen,
die ganzen Ereignisse
hinter sich zu lassen,
nicht, um sie in dem Sinn
mit ins Grab zu nehmen.
Das ist auch
verständlich und nachvollziehbar.
Viele wollen nicht mehr
damit konfrontiert werden.
Ich bin eine Ausnahme
und habe mir erlaubt,
etwas über diese Geschichte
zu schreiben.
Margrith,
wie hast du diese Zeit erlebt?
Das war sicher eine intensive Zeit,
als das Buch entstand.
Ich war nicht so erfreut, dass
alles wieder hervorgekramt wurde.
Ich dachte an Zeitungsartikel,
an die vielen negativen Sachen.
Ich war gar nicht erfreut.
Im Theater Uri in Altdorf
steht eine Lesung an.
Schaffner bestreitet den Abend
mit Autorin Tanja Polli,
die seine Erinnerungen
in Buchform gebracht hat.
"Die Kollegen der Uniformpolizei
kannten ihn nicht,
packten ihn unsanft am Arm und
stiessen ihn in den Kastenwagen."
Sie waren während dieser Zeit
eigentlich auch Schauspieler.
Beginnt man nicht,
zu denken wie diese Leute?
Diese Gefahr besteht,
sie besteht.
Man hat mir unterstellt,
ich hätte mit der Zeit begonnen,
selektiv zu rapportieren, bevorzugte
Leute nicht mehr zu notieren.
Entstehen da
nicht auch Freundschaften?
Doch, das gibt es,
aber da muss man aufpassen,
wie weit man
diese Freundschaften pflegt.
Das hat mir
lange zu schaffen gemacht.
Ich habe mit diesen Leuten kommuni-
ziert wie mit eigenen Kollegen,
einfach etwas distanzierter.
Das wurde nicht verstanden,
das sei ein Missbrauch.
Daran hatte ich lange zu kauen,
weil es Missbrauch
im weitesten Sinn war.
Ich war der Auffassung, ich tue
etwas Sinnvolles für den Staat.
Damals hat das gestimmt, aber heute
muss ich mir an den Kopf greifen
und sagen: "Nein,
das kann es nicht gewesen sein."
Im Sommer 1980
war das AJZ in Betrieb.
Dennoch kam Zürich nicht zur Ruhe.
(Megafon)
Mitmarschieren - solidarisieren.
* Knall *
Viele Jugendliche hatten
nach der ersten Ausschreitungswelle
ein Strafverfahren am Hals.
4'000 Demonstranten forderten,
die Anklagen
sollten fallengelassen werden.
Polizei und Aktivisten
gerieten wiederholt aneinander.
Diese Ereignisse in Zürich,
diese Gewaltanwendungen haben
ganz besonders dazu beigetragen,
dass man ...
dass die Bewegung erst
in eine Ecke gedrängt wurde,
dass man sie nicht so ernst nahm,
wie man das
eigentlich hätte tun müssen.
(Polizeifunk)
Uniformpolizei in Schwierigkeiten!
Wir werden angegriffen.
Kann man jemanden vorbeischicken?
* Knall *
(Polizeifunk) Habt ihr das
mitbekommen? Beeilt euch!
An Baustelle Weite Gasse
wird Munition gesammelt,
d.h. Pflastersteine.
Während der Jugendbewegung wurden
fast 4'000 Aktivisten verhaftet.
In rund 1'000 Fällen
kam es zu einem Strafverfahren.
Viele waren im Gefängnis.
Und es gab auch Leute,
die in Isolationshaft waren.
Die breite Masse und das Volk
fanden das okay.
Daraufhin gründeten wir
ein Komitee gegen Isolationshaft.
Dadurch haben wir
den Gefangenen gezeigt:
Wir sind da, ihr seid nicht allein,
und wir holen euch raus.
Das war natürlich nicht so einfach,
aber als mentale Unterstützung
ist so etwas sehr wichtig.
Nach einer Polizeirazzia
schloss der Stadtrat
das AJZ im September 1980.
Die Jugendlichen waren frustriert.
Es war ein Experiment,
das man im Aufbau
nicht bereits abbrechen darf.
Dann ist klar,
dass es scheitern muss.
Wir befanden uns im Aufbau,
sechs bis acht Wochen waren es.
Wir hätten besser klarmachen müssen,
dass es nicht unsere Sache ist,
alle Probleme
selbst lösen zu wollen,
denn es sind Probleme der Stadt.
Die erste Hauptbedingung ist,
dass man sie nicht allein lässt,
sondern man ihnen von aussen hilft,
um v.a. diejenigen Probleme
zu bewältigen,
die nicht unbedingt direkt mit einem
Jugendhausbetrieb zu tun haben,
z.B. die Bewältigung
des Drogenproblems,
Bewältigung von Fragen
im Zusammenhang
mit
Jugendkriminalität und ähnlichem.
Erneut ging Zürichs Jugend
auf die Strasse
und kämpfte
für die Wiedereröffnung des AJZ.
Die Gewaltspirale drehte sich
auf beiden Seiten weiter.
* Knall *
* Unverständliche Rufe *
Nazischweine!
* Knall *
Es war ein Auf und Ab
von Schliessungen,
Wiedereröffnungen und Demos.
Es war auch eine Art Sisyphusarbeit.
Sofort nach der provisorischen
Wiedereröffnung über die Festtage
ist das AJZ wieder zum
Treffpunkt der Hängerszene geworden.
Fixer, Drogenhändler,
Jugendliche auf der Kurve
prägen die Atmosphäre.
Die wenigen, die sich aktiv für
eine Verbesserung eingesetzt haben,
resignieren immer mehr.
Die schlauen Politikerinnen
und Politiker wussten:
"Das AJZ bleibt zwei Jahre."
"Nachher wollen wir dort
sowieso etwas anderes bauen."
Es wurde nicht wirklich getragen.
Heute morgen kurz vor 9 Uhr.
Bauarbeitertrupps haben bereits
einen guten Teil
des Zürcher AJZ abgebrochen.
Ein Handstreich
des Zürcher Stadtrats,
bis kurz vor der Aktion
geheim gehalten.
Sie räumen einfach alles,
aber das Problem selber,
die Drogen und die ganze
Jugendszene, lösen sie nicht.
Sie lösen es so:
abreissen und fertig Schluss.
Sie verjagen uns,
hetzen uns die ganze Zeit herum.
* Trommelklänge *
Ist das eine Lösung oder was?
Die Lösung ist,
jahrelang leer stehende Häuser
zu besetzen - ohne Polizei.
Spekulationshäuser besetzen.
* Applaus *
(Sprechchor) AJZ.
Nach dem Abbruch des AJZ
ging der Aufbruch in veränderter Form
und Zusammensetzung weiter.
Der Antrieb und die Energie
der Jugendbewegung
haben massgebend dazu beigetragen,
dass Zürich heute
als tolerante, weltoffene Stadt
mit kultureller Vielfalt
wahrgenommen wird.
Passend zu ihrer eigenen Geschichte
holt Willy Schaffner
Fredy Meier in Zürich
mit einem Auto
aus den 80er-Jahren ab.
Bei sich daheim in Gurtnellen
will er den einstigen Aktivisten
in ein Geheimnis einweihen.
Unterwegs reden sie
über Gott, die Welt
und natürlich
über die Zürcher Jugendbewegung.
In den 80ern war sehr wichtig:
sammeln, aber auch jagen.
Zu den Sammelobjekten
gehörte der Stern dort vorne.
Das Ding war ein Symbol des
Reichtums, des Protzens, der Bonzen.
Es gab Leute, die eine Sammlung von
über 20 Mercedes-Sternen besassen.
Mecedes-Sterne waren
übrigens auch beliebte Geschenke.
Wenn jemand seinem Schatz
neben den Rosen oder sonst was
einen Mercedes-Stern
als Mitbringsel schenkte,
wurde das höher bewertet
als nur eine Gummischrotpatrone,
die ebenfalls gerne
verschenkt oder mitgebracht wurden.
Aber ein Mercedes-Stern
war immer etwas Spezielles.
Habt ihr das nie mitbekommen?
Ja, sicher. Für uns war das
ganz klar Sachbeschädigung.
Wie hast du dich
bei diesen Demonstrationen gefühlt?
Wenn Scheiben eingeschlagen wurden?
Wenn geplündert wurde?
Wenn man es geschafft hat, die
Scheiben einer Bank einzuschlagen,
war das natürlich grossartig.
Politisch war das ein 1:1.
Scheiben bei der "NZZ" einzuschlagen
und ähnliche Sachen,
das stand politisch
ganz klar für etwas.
Ich persönlich
fand es eher angebracht,
dort Scheiben einzuschlagen.
Und ihr ...
- Es wurde auch applaudiert.
Und ein Teil von euch hat sich
damals das Recht herausgenommen,
zu tun, was ihr wolltet.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Das sage ich ja, natürlich.
Das geht nicht. Irgendwann kommt
der Punkt, an dem ich sagen muss:
"Nein, so nicht."
Sonst können wir einpacken.
Ja.
Und ich habe eine Tochter.
Sie wird bald 15.
Das gibt ab und zu auch
wieder einmal einen Anstoss, um ...
Du wirst also etwas gefordert.
- Ja. Ja, ja.
* Sanfte Geigenklänge *
* Kanon und Gigue in D-Dur
von Johann Pachelbel *
(Mann) Was tut ihr denn da?
(Frau) Wir machen eine Zeitung
namens "Eisbrecher".
(Mann) Freiheit für
alle Pinguine in Grönland.
* Polizeisirene *
* Sanfte Geigenklänge *
(Mann) Darf ich die Frage stellen,
wer jetzt eigentlich
beim Fernsehen für Ordnung sorgt.
* Polizeisirene *
* Sanfte Geigenklänge *
* Unverständlicher Sprechchor *
(Mann) Ja, Pflastersteine
habt ihr auch noch.
Du warst ja
ziemlich lange eingebuchtet.
D.h., du musstest
eine Strafe absitzen.
Warum eigentlich?
Was hattest du auf dem Kerbholz?
Was hattest du verbrochen?
Alle Anklagepunkte
waren erstunken und erlogen.
Der beste Anklagepunkt war:
Benutzung von öffentlichem Luftraum
zu politischen Zwecken,
als ich zusammen mit einer Freundin
ein Transparent aufgehängt hatte.
Ein anderes Mal wurde behauptet,
ich hätte einen Container angezündet
und auf die Strasse gestellt.
Stimmt nicht. Das war ich nicht.
Faktisch erhielt ich
eine Gefängnisstrafe von 14 Monaten.
Sogar wirklich rechte Anwälte
und andere Gesetzesvertreter
sagten mir damals,
das sei eigentlich
ein Gesinnungsurteil.
Dadurch hat sich der Angeklagte
schuldig gemacht.
Erstens der fortgesetzten,
einfachen Körperverletzung,
der wiederholten
und fortgesetzten Sachbeschädigung,
der fortgesetzten Brandstiftung,
des wiederholten Landfriedensbruchs,
der Gewalt und Drohung
gegen Behörden und Beamte,
weshalb er zu bestrafen ist.
Für mich war das Entsetzen gross,
als ich rausgekommen war.
Das waren nur neun Monate,
aber in diesen neun Monaten
wurde die Bewegung sehr verhärtet.
Die Repression war da,
die Leute mochten nicht mehr,
z.T. hatten Leute, die ich kannte,
ziemlich Drogen konsumiert.
Das war nicht so lustig.
Ich hatte verschiedene Phasen
in meinem Leben,
in denen es mir weniger gut ging,
in anderen besser.
Jetzt bin ich seit ein paar Jahren
eigentlich wieder sehr zufrieden.
Ich kann wieder kreativ sein,
wieder schreiben, wieder malen.
Eigentlich ist für dich
alles ziemlich gut gelaufen.
Zu gut.
- Es gab nie grosse Probleme.
Aber irgendwann machte es Wutsch,
dann berichtete die "WoZ"
mit einem Foto
und von heute auf morgen war
alles anders. Wie war das bei dir?
Weisst du, auch gefühlsmässig?
Für mich war das
ein ziemlicher Schlag.
Ich sass im Büro, als die "Wochen-
Zeitung" meine Enttarnung brachte.
Ich musste das Büro
schlagartig verlassen.
Meine Frau
musste das Geschäft verlassen
und nullkommaplötzlich verschwinden:
Das war nicht sehr angenehm.
V.a. für meine Frau
und meine Familie war es unangenehm.
Ich selbst konnte damit umgehen,
aber es war
keine angenehme Situation.
* Entspannte, italienische Popmusik:
"Sereno E" von Drupi *
Wir haben Hunger.
Ich esse so eines.
Das sind übrigens Krapfen.
Aus der Gegend?
Ja, die gibt es, wenn Chilbi-Zeit
ist, Kirchweihe, weisst du.
Aha. Mmh.
Was mit Zürich jetzt los ist ...
Zürich wurde auf eine Art fett,
fett im Sinn von genug.
Alles ist da.
Du musst gar nie mehr jemanden ...
Du findest niemanden,
dem etwas fehlt.
Du kannst dich
mit niemandem zusammenschliessen,
dem auch etwas fehlt,
weil alle alles haben.
Und jetzt geht es in den Weinkeller,
Willy. Oder nicht?
Nein, jetzt geht es
ins Privatarchiv.
Ehrlich?
- Ja, sicher.
Schau dir diesen Tisch an!
"Verfügung."
Das sagt dir bestimmt etwas.
"Entla..."
"Proteskl..."
Das hast du alles gesammelt.
- Jawohl.
Das ist das Zeichen
der Schwarzen Katze.
Ja, richtig: die Choppergruppe,
die bei uns auch
lange im Fokus gestanden hat.
(Mann) Radio Schwarze Katze,
gestresst und überlastet,
aber immer noch da.
Radio Schwarze Katze.
Der absolut subjektivistische
Monosender der Zürcher Grauzone.
Hallo, Sonntagswixer, es steht
ein Grosseinsatz der Bullen bevor.
Das ist kein Witz,
auch wenn es so klingt.
He, einpacken! Die Bullen kommen!
(Frau) Aber wir wollten doch
noch die Prani-Diskussion senden,
aber das müssen wir auf nächstes Mal
verschieben. Tschüss.
Hast du etwas, was du verfasst hast?
Das ist z.B. ein Bericht,
das war eine Aufgabe von mir.
Von 1984.
Ja, das war gegen Schluss
meiner Insiderzeit.
"Der Aufstand im Kino Xenix."
"... über Nicaragua."
Die Namen in meinem Bericht
wurden dann registriert.
Aber weisst du,
in diesen Berichten kommen Begriffe
vor wie z.B. linksextrem.
Wenn im Xenix z.B. ein Film läuft,
der als linksextrem beurteilt wird.
Sind dann Zuschauer, die
diesen Film schauen, Linksextreme?
Zwei Jahre lang gab es täglich
oder zwei- bis dreimal pro Woche
Aktionen in der Stadt Zürich.
Deshalb nahm man es anders wahr,
wenn Leute solche Anlässe besuchten.
Wir dachten wirklich,
Leute würden dadurch motiviert
oder würden deshalb
an solchen Aktionen teilnehmen.
Diese Einstellung herrschte damals.
Durftest du das behalten?
Ich meine ...
Das sind ja alles geheime Dokumente.
In der Regel
ist nach der Pensionierung ...
Wieso durftest du
das Zeug behalten?
Dürfen? Ich habe es einfach getan.
- Ah.
Sorry, es mag vielleicht
etwas grenzwertig sein,
aber ich habe jetzt
zum x-ten Mal gesagt,
dass diese Originalakten
jetzt tatsächlich hier sind.
Aber sie kommen ins Stadtarchiv
zur späteren Auswertung.
Wie hat man dazumal gearbeitet?
Wie haben Insider funktioniert?
Wie sind Vorgesetzte
damit umgegangen? Usw.
Das ist eigentlich der Grund.
Am Ende des Ausflugs
messen sich die einstigen Gegner
in einem Pétanque-Einzel,
dem sog. Tête-à-tête.
Wie viel Überwindung
hat es gebraucht,
einem Menschen wiederzubegegnen,
den Sie vor 40 Jahren
ausspioniert haben?
Eigentlich gar keine Überwindung.
Ich finde es toll, dass man nach
40 Jahren zusammen diskutieren kann,
was damals passiert ist.
Beide haben daraus
die nötigen Lehren gezogen.
Diese Zeit prägte unser Leben.
Wir haben ehemalige Bewegte
angefragt,
bei diesem Film mitzumachen,
nicht wenige antworteten:
"Wenn ein Spitzel mitmacht,
bin ich nicht dabei."
Warum hast du mitgemacht?
Also, das eine ist eine Funktion.
Polizist oder Spitzel zu sein,
ist eine Funktion.
die man anständig
oder weniger anständig ausüben kann.
Und v.a. sind inzwischen
wirklich 40 Jahre vergangen.
Ich will nicht ein Leben lang
in einer Haltung oder keiner Haltung
gegenüber jemandem verharren.
Mich interessiert,
was Willy zu erzählen hat.
warum was gelaufen war.
Ich habe da keine Berührungsängste.
Und es hat sich gelohnt.
* Ruhige Handorgelklänge *
(Sprechchor) AJZ.
Wenn ich jetzt zurückblicke,
kann ich recht stolz darauf sein.
Wir haben diese Stadt wachgerüttelt.
Das kann man ruhig so sagen.
* Sanfter Popsong: "Siebzehn Jahr,
blondes Haar" von Udo Jürgens *
# 17 Jahr, blondes Haar,
so stand sie vor mir.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Roger Schmid - 2020